well could I went up to way up into the
just on sound days barons house yeah
what did you do I don't know what I did
what was I doing I was hanging with the
kids I spent a lot of time with my
brother Saturday yeah my wife will give
me is so funny that we should talk about
this my wife my wife makes me a better
man and here's why and I have to say
this she'll sit me down sometimes
because I get in my own head and she'll
be like hey hey dude you need to know
something I don't like that you're not
present when you're in the house with
your children yeah and it's about time
put your phone down to be present and I
need to be reminded of that because I
suck at that and because I get into my
own head and there are no excuses be a
father be a husband that's part of your
responsibility and she has to remind me
of that
but I'm talking when I talk to Julia
Julia who I go listen man relationships
are this way man you know you're my wife
makes me a better man she sat me down
she was like I'm not happy with the way
you're behaving it's been this week has
sucked
you haven't been present and everything
else and Chris is like and I figure
curse is gonna be like yeah man he's
gonna tell lesson from this and Chris
goes like this Chris goes ah yeah hey
why don't you just tell her to look
around look around and say you're
welcome yeah I'm like Chris that doesn't
work on a minute that doesn't work at
America oh he's younger dude he's been
married divorced ooh yeah you know how
you know every relationship is
compromising if I love when guys think
like that's how you're gonna run your
your marriage hey hey look around say
you're you're welcome you look around
out you're welcome I give you all this
that doesn't know doesn't [ __ ] work
that doesn't fly so if you're the right
girl she'll give a [ __ ] about know
you're a girl
your girl would [ __ ] try that with
her see what happened that's like the
guy who's the single entendre guy I I'm
gay as in I'm gonna put my dick in his
butt if you know what I mean yeah put it
in there yeah if you know what I mean I
get it I get for him though I [ __ ] guys
if you know what I mean definitely this
and I put this in there yeah I guess
most heavyweights don't need to cut
weight how does the diet plan differ for
them compared to other weight classes oh
man you're talking about extreme
difference because
with you know if you're let's say you
walk around 190 pens you kept 170 you
got to watch everything you put in your
body from the calorie intake the fats
the sugars the carbs like it's a job you
know there's a reason why guys miss
weight but there's also reason why guys
are so diligent about it and they make
sure they know exactly what they're
putting into their body cause every
calorie counts now on the other side of
that with a heavy weight I was always a
guy who maybe is just more of a mental
thing for me I thought I'd gain
advantage by eating all healthy organic
you know I never ate junk food I never
really ate [ __ ] because I thought it
would help me you know with my cardio
and my nutrition in the fight I thought
it was just another advantage over my
opponents because a lot of heavy weights
like I remember when I was fighting
Gabriel Gonzaga I saw him in the lobby
we're fight in Orange County Anaheim
when we're fighting the Anaheim and he's
in the the Hyatt or whenever the finest
hotel and I see him that literally right
before we headed to the fight he's
eating a giant Starbucks latte like I
didn't know if they made the tren tea at
that time he liked the Gonzaga size it
was [ __ ] huge it's like a big gulp
latte iced with caramel in it and he was
eating a giant like doughnut and muffin
I thought all right they're like for me
that gives me a advantage I'm like ooh I
like that I've seen guys in the back
Mitrione before our fight was eating at
Chipotle burrito see I like seeing that
but a lot of heavy weights you know they
can eat [ __ ] because you know that
that's what they're used to and to them
it's not a big deal that we'll have to
make weight you know unless you're a guy
that's at like 170 175 we have to get to
65 then you can usually sweat down the
sonic as well that's fat unless you're
just a monster but yeah a lot of have
you h2 literally whatever they want
which is why you see a lot of their
physiques with like pure doodoo because
they don't care they their discipline
other aspects what they don't have to be
in making weight that makes me think of
Cain Velasquez for some reason he seems
like he's not super ripped but he seems
like he's very very smart
about his diet and everything I thought
was imagine he's really smart about his
diet but do you think he is I think he's
a lot of Mexican
I think he throw the [ __ ] you wants and
he just does so much card in such a
beast yeah so it's on a bodybuilding
contest so he's like if I eat this
[ __ ] nachos Bell Grande you know it
doesn't matter to me so you know I'm
still gonna perform that's what I'm used
to you know again it's not a
bodybuilding contest so you know a lot
of guys will just see what makes them
happy but for him how think it's a
discipline issue but then you got guys
like Calvin who you know even at 85
who's not winning any mr. Olympia
contest you know he is that boxy body
and you know he's kind of the Cain
Velasquez of 185-pound division you know
it's his physiques not impressive but
the skills are I won't say his name I'll
take you guys out there I was at this
gym he trains all these celebrities and
this celebrity was getting ready for
this role and he literally made the gym
stop this is that 8 a.m. literally
everyone stop and watch him do this new
thing over there and it was like that's
amazing Mike well I was I'm not used to
something like what the [ __ ] are we
doing what was he doing it you doing
workout her I bet yeah it's him he's
learned this new craft get ready for
this role okay and he was demonstrating
how good he's giving it was a 15 minute
tape that he recorded on his cell phone
and his agent was there working I that's
a narcissist yeah
what is everyone do it you're too happy
with you go back I'm back your slang in
the weights around and everyone's just
watching this don't like ready get over
like don't take my time okay
he's my time that's you you need because
people don't have around them people
that go shut up
yeah that's what you need people around
you who like you enough to go shut your
[ __ ] face
I agree that's that's what friends do
it's out so we're all together we're all
we do is torture each I don't know will
I love Chris and I don't will the funny
[ __ ] yes Chris for a while but
really more hanging out and it all it is
is one insult after another
yeah do you have a lot of friends who
are comics don't hang out with all con
and it's not because I think we're
better that's just swarm around if you
relate tune you around yeah well my
radio co-host sure you know I didn't
believe it not matching very close
friend now like I love that sir like how
can you not he's just he's a real guy
here's what I love my favorite part
about Matt Serra he hates bullies like
he
Faith's [ __ ] bull and you could see
it like he's a he's a guy who can really
fight doesn't like it oh yeah he doesn't
like guys you know Italy he did stand up
at the Laugh Factory I gotta tell you I
know he I swear to god I'm not just
saying this I thought he was funny he
was very funny as matic he was up there
he he he he committed it was [ __ ] good
bat showed me on his phone and he was so
proud any mention he's like Brian was it
he was very proud of that it's mantle
lips he got so excited he really he goes
he goes come here because I was crying I
was like listen dude you're gonna be
great just go do using and he was
[ __ ] great and funny
yeah well hostel anyway he was so
relieved and he grabs me and he goes to
kiss me and I kind of turned my head and
next thing I know I got it